Shannon is in Arizona
Merry Christmas Shannon welcome to the
Dave Ramsey show how can I help you -
what's up um well I I have a little
problem I'm not sure how to handle like
my mother is 65 she just turned 65 she
moved in with me and March because she
didn't have another place to go I'm a
single mom I make about 40,000 a year
I'm trying to UM work your baby steps
and she doesn't seem to think about just
putting up hangouts a strain on me so
does she have an income Social Security
she has about seven hundred a month and
she uses that for her car insurance and
her car payment and some money that she
owes on to the IRS so she gives me about
two hundred a month but that's including
I pay her cell phone bill and that's
including groceries and everything else
how old are you 39 and you said you make
how much about forty thousand oh cool
and I have two daughters and how old are
them 14 and 11 okay it sounds like that
you have a real hard time telling your
mother no I haven't actually had that
conversation with her ever about
anything yeah I have this woman is a big
as a big personality and she's used to
getting her way am I wrong um no you're
not wrong okay well so
is why does she not work she doesn't
want to she says she's retired well I
would say this mom I brought you in
because it didn't want you to be
homeless I can't afford to keep you
you're too expensive I have a
responsibility to my own daughters and
to my own pocketbook in my own future
and so you can stay for a few more
months but you're gonna have to get a
job and you're gonna have to get your
debt cleaned up so that you can move out
because you cannot stay here the rest of
your life you are not retiring and me
pay for it I don't have that kind of
money I love you and I'm really sorry
that I can't just give you money but I
don't have any money and you're killing
me you're stressing out this situation
so mom I love you so much
I'm gonna tell you the truth and that is
you're gonna have to get a job because
you're broke so that you can get a place
to live you got six months June 1 you're
moving and you know what's gonna happen
when you do that you know do you know
yes yes you do she's gonna have what we
call in Tennessee a duck fit you ever
seen a duck have a fit yeah isn't she in
for sure cuz no one tells her no and no
one sets boundaries with her she does
whatever she wants with her muddy boots
and walks around wherever she wants
she's not mean she's not nasty
she just never accepts no as a possible
answer
and so the end and she's gonna become a
travel agent for guilt trips well I
changed your diaper you'd thank you be
grateful are you ungrateful no I'm not
ungrateful mom I'm broke and I can't
afford to feed you I can't afford to
take care of you and you're able-bodied
and you need to get job
and pay off your IRS and pay off your
car and build you a nice life so you can
be a good grandmother to your grandkids
instead of a parasite bringing down the
future of your own grandchildren I mean
you can be a little nicer than that you
should be really I'm being sarcastic but
you know you've got to deliver this
message because you really can't keep
her can you yeah this is gonna be a very
hard conversation for you because it's
the first time you've ever done this
with your mom and you're 40 years old I
have tried to give her a 30 day notice
and she she says I'm gonna have to take
her to court if I want her out we can do
that if you only do that we'll go into
that tomorrow if that's the way you
returned my kindness of bringing you in
so that you're not homeless is that
you're a belligerent which I can take
you to court and we will do that in the
morning I'll just go get a lawyer and
we'll just get you thrown out in the
street that wasn't what I was trying to
do mom I was trying to help you but you
don't get to decide what happens at my
house god this woman is belligerent who
says that I'm moving in your house and
living there because you're so kind and
if you want me to leave you're gonna
have to take me to court what a jerk
yeah interrupt yeah I'm sorry I'm sorry
for you kiddo it's very tough hey are
you in a good church by chance yes I am
okay where do you live what part of
Arizona um the Queen Creek area okay all
right yeah so you're in a Phoenix
Phoenix suburb right I guess yeah okay
lots of good congregations around there
you probably ought to holler at your
pastor and sit down and talk to him and
maybe he can even help you reason with
your mother because you probably need
somebody in your corner to remind you
that you're not evil and you're not
crazy because you're not you're not out
of line here and again we're not just
putting her in the street we're just
thinking
um we're just thinking you know how mom
this is not work and I just can't do it
and you can't accept that and you've got
to deal with your situation and you
you're able-bodied and there's no reason
you can't work and you're gonna have to
you can't you don't get to just retire
and declare someone else is gonna pay
for it now our life works hold on I'm
gonna send you a copy dr. Henry clouds
book boundaries you're gonna have to
read it over and over and highlight it
and put a little sticky notes all in it
because that's what you're dealing with
it's very painful very painful to have
boundaries with people who refuse to
accept boundaries and you're gonna have
some people in your corner emotionally
to walk you through this I'm so sorry
it's it's harsh but you know just hear
real loud and clear from me you are not
the unreasonable one in this
conversation you are not the crazy one
you are not the ungrateful one you are
not a bad daughter you are not a bad
person what you've described here is
just financial abuse and someone that's
taken advantage of their relationship
with you to bring you harm and it's
toxic as it can be so I'm so sorry again
you know we live in a weird generation
the 40 year olds that are out there the
50 year olds are out there we call them
the Sandwich Generation they're
sandwiched between taking care of their
parents and their kids and the good news
is that I the way to get rid of the
sandwich is just get rid of the bread on
both sides you say mom and dad you need
a plan son you need a plan none of you
is living in the basement we have plans
for our empty nesting years and neither
one of you all are living in the
basement in a matter of fact both of you
move in we may just move out and sell
the house you got a 30 year old in the
basement and a 75 year old in the
basement at the same time good lord help
us but uh that's what's going on out
there and it's because neither group
none of the people in the whole
discussion are handling
well and so one of the one of your goals
ought to be to change your family tree
and declare that you're not going to be
a burden on your children one of your
goals if you're 24 ought to be that it's
time to grow up and not be a burden on
someone else as a matter of fact you
ought to be a contributor to society not
someone who takes from your parents